cette fois pas de kilos en trop ou en
moins cet après midi à monaco alain
prost a remporté une vraie victoire la
2e cette saison quatre grands prix et ce
grand prix ci a été particulièrement
mouvementée michel dhrey ayrton senna en
pole position on y est habitué le
brésilien sur sa lotus renault est
actuellement le plus rapide des pilotes
quel que soit le tracé
monaco c'est le circuit le plus lent
mais aussi le plus difficile c'est un
grand prix qui se gagne à plus de 140 km
de moyenne horaire et les pilotes
effectuent pendant les 78 tours soit 258
kilomètres
plus de 2000 changement de vitesse
l'important monaco c'est de prendre le
commandement de nombreux incidents vont
perturber ce grand prix première victime
patrick tambay dès le premier tour comme
l'an dernier
pendant ce temps ayrton senna caracole
en tête devant alboreto et alain prost
mais sur ce circuit exigeant pour les
transmissions et les boîtes de vitesses
tout peut arriver deuxième victime
le fougueux brésilien sénat moteur cassé
et puis regardez nelson piquet tu veux
doubler patrese la brabham touche le
rail de sécurité
on a frôlé la catastrophe
oui
c'est terminé pour l'ici lauda très
malchanceux cette cg patrese epic est
qui grimacent l'ont échappé belle
chassé croisé en tête de la course
alboreto et frost prenne le commandement
à tour de rôle prost fasse une dernière
fois il se retrouve premier devant de
angelis et 2 c à risque car alboreto
s'arrête à son stand pour changer le
pneu arrière gauche qui s'est dégonflé
l'italien qui aura 40 secondes de retard
va faire une fin de course éblouissante
et se classer finalement deuxièmes
devant de angelis de cesaris warwick et
jacques laffite alain prost a une avance
confortable qui lui permet de prendre
tranquillement la bonne trajectoire pour
économiser les pneus et la mécanique
c'est la deuxième victoire dans la prost
à monette